un voyage en Inde c'est la proposition
faite à 180 petits élèves des écoles
centrales et flamboyant de saintonis des
petits qui ont pendant une année
découvert l'Inde à travers des livres
mais également à travers la fabrication
de petites boîtes dans les ateliers
magiques de la Bibliothèque
départementale tous les enfants ainsi
que leurs parents et professeurs se sont
retrouvés à l'espace Redelé du bas de la
rivière pour clôturer cette belle année
de découverte une journée qui a commencé
au son de la classe orchestre du collège
de la
montagne
nous allons voir un spectacle d'une
danseuse interprète chorégraphe indienne
qui s'appelle do
Baud entre les deux moments du spectacle
nous aurons la classe de moyenne section
de l'École centrale qui nous fera
l'honneur et le plaisir de danser et
c'est tout de suite un plongeon dans la
culture indienne avec dolcy qui nous
emmené aux quatre coins de ce fabuleux
pays ce sont ensuite les tout petits qui
se sont aussi promenés au pays du
tajemal et qui sont entrés en scène sur
une chorégraphie très
bollywoodienne
quand on se produit à l'école ça reste à
l'école et les parents tandis que là on
a pu quand même sortir la production
l'emmener à l'extérieur et cette
possibilité là nous l'avons pas tout le
temps nous en tant que maître et en tant
que je veux dire enseignant on n pas
l'occasion de pouvoir sortir et de se
produire et de montrer à l'extérieur et
c'était important pour les élèves et
surtout de monter sur une vraie scène un
voyage dans le temps et dans l'histoire
du peuplement de la réunion qui s'est
concrétisé à travers une boîte aux
couleurs des différentes escales
indiennes présente du conseil général
qui a salué le travail accompli avec
l'aide des enseignants et la
collaboration des parents toutes les
instituteurs et institutrices ainsi que
les parents nous nous nous nous rendons
compte que en laissant vivre les
potentialités des plus jeunes des
marmailles nous leur offrons pas
seulement un voyage à la découverte d'un
pays mais ça permet aussi un voyage à
l'intérieur de l'enfant et de son propre
corps pour qu'il découvre les gestes
qu'il peut faire l'harmonie et qu'il
puisse avoir également une certaine
confiance et ben pareil danser comme la
classe vient de faire c'est pas facile
moi je saurit pas danser là-dessus hein
et ils ont fait ça avec beaucoup de
talent et c'est pour ça que je voudrais
remercier les parents qui certainement
ont dû répéter aussi avec leurs enfants
les enseignants et également ses enfants
un gros applaudissement une belle
opération dans un espace ouvert à tous
la présidente a une fois de plus rappelé
que l'espace réglé est un lieu ouvert à
toutes formes d'art et d'apprentissage à
l'image de l'atelier de boî goyavier qui
connaît un vrai succès auprès des
habitants du secteur petits et grands et
pour l'occasion un atelier de aîné a
permis aux enfants de se parer des plus
beaux àours l'Inde dans toute sa
splendeur